Another non philosopher that may be considered a
philosopher since we're talking about reality is iron Rand and hor
philosophy of objectivism.
What are your thoughts on her sense of taking this
idea of reality, calling her philosophy, objectivism,
and a kind of starting at the idea that you really
could know everything and it's pretty obvious.
And then from that you can derive an ethics about how to live life.
Like what is the,
what is the good ethical life and all the virtue of selfishness,
all that kind of stuff. Uh, so you talked a lot of academic philosophers,
so I'd be curious to see from the perspective of like,
is she somebody that's, uh, taken seriously at all?
Uh, why she dismissed as I see from my distant perspective,
by serious philosophers and also like your own personal thoughts of like,
is there some interesting bits that you find inspiring in her work or?
Okay, so I N Rand, um,
I've had so many exceedingly intelligent
students basically give me her books
and basically say, please Dr. Basilica,
read this book and I'll tell them, yes, thank you.
I've read this book before and then why don't we engage in, you know,
let me put it this way. They're religious about iron rant. Okay. So to them,
Iran represents some type of way of life, right?
Her objectivism. Um,
now why is she not taken seriously by philosophers in general?
Well, let me put it this way. Um,
philosophers in general tend to get pretty,
I guess you could call it they're they're so kind of scientists,
but with words, I always called philosophy.
When I describe it to someone who's going to take a philosophy class.
I say it's basically math problems, like word math problems.
Okay. So that's basically what it is.
So they take words very seriously and they're very formal.
And definitions very seriously. Yeah. So they all want to get on the same page.
So they're not, so there is no confusion.
So for Iran to basically say you can know everything and, you know,
and establish ethics from that. I think philosophers automatically say no.
Now that doesn't mean, I say no. Um, in fact, uh, we even,
we have at my university, a wonderful business school.
And when you walk into the, uh, Dean of the business school's office,
fine, Rand is everywhere. So it's,
so I want to say that not all academics are anti fine Rand. Um,
and in fact,
I don't think philosophers are either except that they don't teach [inaudible]
. Okay. So in one sense, you could say that because they don't teach her they're
being exclusive in what they teach or very particular perhaps is another way to put it.
Yeah. It's hard to know where to place people like her because, um, you know,
do you put Albert Como as a philosopher?
So I guess what's the good term for that,
like literary philosophers or whatever the term is.
It's annoying to me that the academic philosophers get to own the word
philosophy. Cause like,
it's just like people who think deeply about life is quote.
I think about his philosophy. And like, to me, it's like, all right,
so I know niches another person that's probably not respected in the
philosophy circles because he is full of contradictions full of,
uh.
He's just my favorite philosopher. Oh really? Yes. I absolutely love Nicha.
So he's deaf, you know, I love people that are full of ideas,
even if they're full of contradictions and niches and Iran is also
that I'm able to, um,
look past the obvious ego that's there on the page. And, uh,
the fact that she actually has in my view, a lot of wrong ideas, uh,
but there's a lot of interesting tidbits to pick up. And, uh, the same,
same goes with Nisha. And, um,
I'm weirded out by the religious aspect here on both the people who like
by and Rand and people who completely dismiss her. I just kind of see it as, Oh,
well,
can we just read a few interesting things and get inspired by it and move on as
opposed to find anything?
Is there something you find about her work that's interesting to you? Um,
or her personality or any of that?
Oh, I think she's fascinating. Um, I don't dismiss her. Um,
she was a woman who reached a level of success with her mind
at a time when that was difficult. So, I mean,
she's definitely worth looking at for, for even that reason. Um,
but also, um, her idea, I guess,
part of the situation with random, first of all, I think that, um,
her work is you have to it's misinterpreted. Okay.
And I think that's the same with Nisha. Like a lot of people think that I'm in,
in fact it is the case that niche's writing
before the 20th century. So he's got, you know, he's somewhat,
his rhetoric is sexist and racist and you know, of the time period,
right. He was a well educated philosopher of that time
period. However, um,
his books are amazing and niche's philosophy is
incredible. And I think that,
I think that's what you're saying about ran too. And I agree. I mean,
I think that, that, um, we get caught up. I mean,
likely we should,
and we should contextualize these thinkers in the time period within which they
are, we should not forgive their, you know,
cause there were people during this time that were, you know,
a feminist and not racist and things like that. And you know, so,
but uh, each has merit. I mean,
I would say Nisha is an, I,
you did ask me to talk about some of the books that made the largest impact on
me and the niches gay science is one of them is one of the best books
ever. In my opinion.
I do think mutual is a,
I don't know about exactly sexist. He certainly was sexist,
but it felt like he didn't get laid much in his life.
It felt like it was extra sexist. I was like,
his theories on women are like angry. He seems frustrated.
It's like, all right, calm down, buddy. Uh, the fate of philosophers,
I just ignore everything which is says about women.